joining me now on the YouTube stage here
at PAX Prime a veritable murderers row
of virtual murderers and video game fans
hi guys everyone we're gonna go down the
line here I'm Chris waters from gamespot
what you guys just introduced sells real
quick going down the line starting with
you I'm Colin Moriarty from kind of
funny i'm jeff cannata from dlc and we
have concerns i'm craig skills to miss
from ScrewAttack i'm anthony carboni
from we have concerns and I'm Donnie
O'Dwyer from gamespot okay five good
gentle they got all the lower thirds in
the right spot yeah good Josh Shaw
everybody works picks up it's a
professional operation did you have us
announcer own names cuz you forgot no
Craig I did not forget I just wanted you
to do my work for him again classic host
move it's good all right so you guys are
all gathered here with a list each of
you has your top five games of the year
so far been through about eight months
of gaming and we're gonna have a little
lively chat hmm about what games you uh
what games are on your list what games
you think Iran everyone else's list what
games are on your list your list alone
wait wait this is top top five of 2015
yes yeah oh wow I got our I thought it
was just at pax Oh Craig no always it's
all right your force in line yeah get to
thinking real quick I can think Colin
let's start with you one of your games
what what's your number one uh dying
light is high ball one guy but number
one goal zombats nobody else got dying
light on this no Daniel Dwyer let no one
else is dying right number one man it's
uh I think it's a really impressive game
I'm surprised people are not talking
about a more the parkour is also best
game of the year so far yes Wow yes
Techland stepped up I didn't know
Techland had this in them yeah and I
thought it was very impressive parkour
is great I like the trio of upgrade
trees in it stories fun I mean zombies
are kind of boring now but I think it's
a really really fantastic game and
especially like what I this is a year
where I played a lot of open world games
and I feel like this is the most
impressive one I enjoy the hell out of
this game a lot of people give me crap
about it haha not only is dying like not
the best game this year not even the
best game out of Poland oh that's not
nice Danny but all that game of course
mr. Dwyer be a witcher 3 wild hunt now
you're number one well yeah yeah I'm who
who else has it on the list yeah have
any way I'm not rid of all Oh were they
were the only I think I doubt that's
what I doubt I i was i was bored i was
bored all through the witcher 3 there's
things you could do everywhere that are
hello I was picking a lot of flowers I
was following a lot of Matt points just
play with I was a second off all the
boxes it was fine it was a fire the game
waivers better than hearthstone as well
hahaha don't make your list Carboni you
seem to be Hootin and Hollerin ah my the
number one on my list this year's
blood-borne blood-borne we had boy
that's just got blood-borne yep right
there yeah there we go I never played a
Souls game before it love it absolutely
love it have you played souls before
Anthony oh yeah so what like what do you
like about this as like that distinguish
itself or carried the torch through what
I loved about it is it kept all of the
mysteriousness of the world that you get
in Dark Souls it kept the incredibly
technical combat that you have but
because it upped sort of the the speed
of the combat and because it wasn't
being as forcefully obtuse as any other
Souls games I did we trying to fit it to
Cindy order I dare you to describe a
Souls game without the word of Jews
coming up I can't I'm sorry I can i yeah
you know it just added a lot of things
that that really appealed to me
personally I was over the sort of rusty
rusty night in a castle aesthetic that's
not kind of my jam to begin with so I
like this sort of more Victorian play
agera and I love the idea of a gun as a
pairing yes world where a gun is your
parry is a very foreboding world that's
a good mechanic right there yeah it's
also it's one of the most like
satisfying feelings and you nail it as
well get the timing it's just like oh
I'm get one of those those giant
werewolves right between the eyes oh
it's so good that's that'll put it at
number one for you yes all right Craig
what about you my man okay um
okay here's the thing Steve behaving
himself oh jeez I'm in an attic me I'm
gonna say a game that that probably
nobody out there's played yet but I
spent a ton of time with and I am
absolutely in love with and that is
super mario maker it is the best game of
the freaking year so when we were sent
come up with your list i sent a side
list that was it's unfair because all of
these things are not out yet yeah and
mario maker is not the top about this is
a conversation yeah i do it so far but
so far but i think i think the original
subject line did not have so far in it
and I got varies i got like nervous i
had an anxiety attack from the address
well Greg tells us about mario maker
what do you got well no I like seriously
I've been playing I've been cheating the
system because you because you have a
we've had the game for a week or so
right and the and the ideas that unlocks
different things as you as you play it
more right so I figured out I can game
the system by setting my wii u to
further dates ahead and unlocking more
things to play with the only an employed
at the end of the year so far my god
enjoy like creating or guess like okay
so here's the thing right not only am i
having an amazing time creating things
and it is like I'm just throwing crap on
the wall and it's fun it's fun I don't
even know I was good at making Mario
levels than I am but not only that every
time i log on i'm playing a new mario
game that i've never played before and i
love the idea of getting from point A to
point B and I think a bunch of crap in
the way and trying to figure out how to
do that and I got that every single time
it is totally different it's it's the
best if you're a fan of Mario it's it's
the only game you'll need well there's
something wonderful about you know the
Mario series is the most universally
loved and the most universally
accessible video game series there is in
history and the fact that you can like
you said always sit down and never run
out of Mario no is amazing and the thing
about it is that you can play the game
that people make levels that are really
hard some people make gate levels that
are super easy some people make levels
we don't even have to touch the
controller and it goes through and you
feel like you accomplished something I
can't even touch the controller and you
feel like you're the best Mario boy that
sounds like sorcery to me and I can't
all right Jeff your number one hears of
the storm heroes of the storm yeah
working that MOBA game yes I have I
think blizzard fixed MOBAs you know 28
million people playing the wrong mo but
this whole time so why it is i put i
have two days ago i think i played my
1000th match a lot of here's the storm I
love it I have fallen in love it's
compulsive it is pure perfect teamwork
it's to me its equivalent of playing a
game of pickup basketball the level of
skill and the the amount of teamwork
involved i think it prevents all the
things that made me not want to play
mobos it got rid of all that stuff yeah
it it's the matches are shorter their
streamlined their lean the heroes play
wildly differently from one another and
it uses all that lore that I love from
playing all the other Blizzard games
that i'm addicted to as well fantastic
yeah well my number ones already been
mentioned the witcher 3 and hunt
fantastic although recently I've been
sitting down to try to play the witcher
3 and what do I end up playing but
Rockit Lee yes yeah fantastic anyone
else put that one on there yes that was
a late entry onto mine because I had
been I had been traveling during the
release window of rocket League and I
was so scared that I was going to log on
and be the worst player in the world
rocket League and I am but I love it
what still even if you're not that great
at him you're getting hosed you'll have
so much fun it's a fantastic game I
can't believe what they did with this
game like when I saw this a PSX I was
like this is going to be special there's
gonna be a special game it's the VP of
the studio is uh is Jeremy Dunham who
used to work with me at IGN when I was
still there and he's he's doing his
thing over there in the game they just
announced yesterday the game sold a
million copies honesty Dean yeah you
know in addition to the millions they
put out on PS Plus in about a month well
it's pretty amazing it would have been
the easiest thing in the world for
rocket League to be a gimmicky game
right like a silly over-the-top gimmicky
game but it is all that stuff it's all
good but in the right way yeah it could
have been the Metroid soccer game that's
the animal God than that it's not so
yeah that thing is like they it was in
development for so long like I was
talking to cliff lesinski earlier like
the guy you made it David
would like he'd made the vehicles for
Unreal Tournament 2003 like that's how
long ago they were like thinking about
this game mode and it's just like as
somebody who like we play soccer
together I pick up games like I played
football my whole life in the UK and
Ireland like this is the most like
playing football than any like fifa Pro
Evolution we are playing as a team cuz
it's all about like where you're
supposed to be on the pitch distributing
the ball and then like actually how your
foot connects with the ball how your car
connects with it well I is more like
soccer than FIFA knows i'm not a huge
sports game fan historically but i
always love a good video game version of
soccer yeah it translates so well and
especially when they add in our Katy
element something like super mario
strikers yes Sega soccer slam NBA Jam
NFL blitz yeah I think you make a good
point Danny that it feels almost like
you're inside the foot yeah yeah a
player it's it's not where FIFA tries to
you know model the entire body and all
the movements are so realistic this is
like just the footwork and it's like
magic that you're right inside that
moment of connecting with the ball and
you know that moment where you're like
playing with a buddy and like the ball
comes over and it's an open goal the
goalies over there and you swing and it
just [ __ ] goes hits the post the same
thing that happens in this yes like I
need percent of my shots yeah yeah yeahs
Rock expense I there's no dying light
but it's it's a fantastic hi well done i
tell you say one of my favorite things
about it is also something that's in
another one of my favorite games that
we'll talk about later but the leveling
system and the kind of this the stick
and carrot of keeping you interested is
so good in rocket League because it's
purely aesthetic yeah uh which doesn't
make I don't have to worry about coming
on and playing rocket League for the
first time with somebody who has the
most insanely tricked-out car because it
doesn't matter and at the same time
storm it's really good about giving you
the experience points that you deserve
for little things like assists in
participation and all the things it's
almost like a good shooter in the way it
levels you up anybody have any good
shooters on their lists shooters Anthony
splatoon hahaha shooter
that is an incredible game you know
excited he is very sad does this so I
feel like it kills everyone who plays it
with joy like oh ma know cosplay here
yeah how much okay I'm gonna say
something small tune is not that good Oh
haryana that good it's not that fun I
much all right what don't you like about
it it's it's did you guys see it you
want him to dance again you'll see ya I
don't know just something gravity to me
I just what do you like about it Anthony
so what I love about it is number one
like I was talking about there is this
feeling of cooperation and also you
always get a little something every time
you play you know and it's not as
directly competitive as other shooters
are so if somebody's just starting out
you can help your team as much just by
like hanging out in a corner and trying
to do my best st. around yeah there are
different spots that are great for
different people i think the different
weapons classes are much deeper than
people initially think they are and the
amount of strategy that you can put into
the different classes if you have one
person with a roller that can like make
a pathway for you through a bottleneck
so you can take over part of it with
your like gattling gun I mean there's a
lot going on that is really wonderful
plus I just love the aesthetic I love
buying shoes I like getting hats best
fashion in the game that's fashion yeah
ever since I see a theme on the games he
likes ya cousin hats shoes hat well that
the recent addition on my list is galaxy
oh yeah Lexie yeah total talk about some
fast-paced shooting at yeah that is that
is a game that it's fast-paced that is
not a game that will make you feel good
about yourself very often when it does
it really does it's a game where many
times I've had to set the controller
down and like take a minute to just
recover from the fact that I died on the
fourth episode right at the end whatever
but it's sublime that the systems work
so well with one another the the
shooting with the upgrade system with
how the enemies behave with how that the
maps are laid out the risk reward of
constantly wanting to keep fighting
things to get an extra bit of scrap
salvage stuff because you might want to
upgrade something but risk
that you'll lose everything it's it's an
incredible mixture of that roguelike
with that shooter and it's I think I
think it's one of the best games of the
year for sure my shooter on the list I'm
actually surprised if any of you guys
have this one on there cuz it kind of
fell off pretty fast evolved oh yeah
anybody know you got Isaac you guys all
giving me like the like yeah all this a
great example of if you can't build that
community quick enough a game that's
entirely online is gonna die yeah
everybody good titanfall kind of enough
yeah which was another game I really
left cos ya hey there was there was
three weeks out titanfall that we were
all in love with and I feel like there
was four days of evolved that we were
all ugly enamored with all men I flip
monster matches long into the summer
time just like that feeling of just
tearing apart an entire team of other
people like just the end of lopsidedness
of it like it creates that power fantasy
so much greater cuz you're the most like
like at like when you get the match goes
right and you're like playing it right
you're just like toying with them and
it's so sad as [ __ ] whitey really and I
get off ha why do you think of fellow
why do you think it didn't I feel like
it's because I feel like the immediate
experience of playing and a lot of the
hunter experience that you run around a
lot and don't have it a lot like that
pursuit game if you have an evasive
monster that can vitiated so much of the
game where like the tension just falls
out not really engaged because you just
feel like you're running through the
darkness trying to find a monster that
you're never going to catch up with
because you need your team to work in
tandem and use their abilities the right
way and if they're not you can just be
like this daisy chain of like rats
following the Pied Piper never catch me
I don't know is i think it was above and
beyond the gameplay though i think this
is a great example of how you market a
game and how you give you know things
like pre-orders and retailer specific
things i felt like there was a chart of
all the different ways to buy evolve and
i couldn't follow it it was the most it
was hard to do to our that I had ever
seen in my life and I think what that
did is instead of making people feel
like they were buying the version of
evolved that was tailored to them it
made them feel like they were always
buying a version of evolved that was
missing something like the whole thing
all right well we're coming down to it
so we haven't like hit all of our top 5s
let's just go down
you gots to round out your list as best
as you can and maybe hit one highlight
so Colin you started off with blood you
started I'm sorry with dying light best
game with you yes the best game of the
year she got off I got rocket League
Craig and I were talking about Megaman
Legacy Collection is awesome Mega Man 3
is my favorite game of all time so I
really enjoyed playing that and going
through the challenge that gets really
special I got to give a shout out to
until dawn until dawn is awesome and I
was really really shocked by how super
massive out Quantic Dream Quantic Dream
with this gun and ways that can fork and
like your decisions impact your actions
and the possibilities is just staggering
it's also i really think that i was
really surprised if sony hadn't gotten
more behind this because i think
supermassive has a series on their hands
here not in terms of that they can't use
these same kids again but every two
years releasing a new interactive movie
basically is cool and I think Quantic
Dream really needs to pay attention to
how they made this game playable so if
not we're dying light until dawn might
be now it's my favorite surprise of the
year so far uh and i don't know i would
probably put which agree on that list so
i think that'll be my my five that's a
solid five Jeff what's that you got
galaxy on there yeah I got galaxy I got
Witcher 3 years I God here's the storm
you know I'd love to shout out some
smaller games like hand of fate which I
thought was fantastic her story which I
thought was fantastic story yet but I
think the highlight that I it's on your
list oh yeah yeah it's great and it's
fascinating unique and different it's
like investigation in a game so many
games ape investigation but this one
makes you feel like you're actually
pursuing mysteries and like coming up
with your own way to do it not just
choosing one of the paths to do it on
yeah completely agree with that but the
the big highlight that I wanted to hit
is pillars of eternity pillars of
eternal yeah incredible fantastic
wonderful throwback those old baldur's
gate games that I loved when I was
younger and it's an excellent game that
does not feel out of time it doesn't
feel outdated it it's it's still as
vibrant and fun to play now as those
games were in their day so what ya
pretty stunning accomplishment to create
something that feels like so much of a
relic of the past but still feel so
vital and accessible and like totally
worth playing a great storytelling you
know it has excellent storytelling
cool systems and it's a great game
that's all it lists all right Craig
perhaps mr. communicators earlier can
you can you give me one more i'll just
checking his phone like best cases of it
I don't like it yeah you can have
splatoon off my list Oh take splittin no
no splatoon are you sure don't list
raining here oh let's see I you know
honestly the one thing I had when I was
put the other my list of top five games
at packed all right chardon okay here's
here's another like hot opinion right
the oculus over there yeah I think
that's making things you can see my
lady's not getting anywhere i really go
this year I like youtube gaming just get
my msi that kid right there you're the
real hero 15 oh yeah no i I've mission
this to somebody for him I think oculus
it's a really really cool tech that
everybody should experience yes I think
it's going to fail miserably oh that's a
whole other 17 to 20 15 another it will
be argued I sure do not allowed we're
not lettin my bat Yankee fan conformed
be like yeah it's really underrated what
what soon thank you right there now yeah
you won the carbon money back him into a
corner and he has to admit the truth
anything you feel our US general
splinter doin we saw Brock la commune
galaxy blood-borne rocket League and I
think my fifth one was I was reluctant
to put this on actually and when I put
it on I felt like I can't believe I'm
doing this I put our come night on there
oh what r come right on there here's why
a lot of the stuff that i was playing
this year it's still in early access is
still like in beta and still not come
out yet just like mine
back burner because like Jeff and I were
talking a lot about darkest dungeon I
played so much dark I just dungeon sasa
but technically darkest dungeon is early
released technically that also gave me
indigestion every out yeah so I did I
didn't know if I I didn't know if I
could put something on that isn't
technically finished yet but getting IV
our tech man but i think the oculus yeah
oculus you know we good nobody's gonna
want to wear a freakin headset in the
living room buddy Danny on fire he
showed up at the cowgirl heaven what do
you got I agree at blood-borne I got all
this I can't fail I can't remember them
and which one of all times adorable and
rock and leave we talked about on my
other two our project cars any any love
for budget cars though not get to play
enough of it it's a really good car
driving game okay that's why I like you
place on your playing at your desk with
the paddles in the shifter yeah I've got
a wheel at my desk I can go and like
just do the hockenheimring in like an f1
car or in like a go-kart and it's just
perfect the best driving in replayed
that and I didn't city skylines cometh
this year yes sab did yeah all eyes I
game was awesome likely break in like it
came out the week after Max's folded
like it just like horrible but it shows
you how like that audience for SimCity
was just not like service for such a
long time and they those guys were
making like weird games the bed like
simulating public services forever
coming out of Finland and then they
release this game and it's just like
killing it on Steam it's doing
incredibly well in the mod support for
it is fascinating and like the stories
of people the way their cities have like
gone wrong or like that weird social
experiments they've tried are just
wonderful coming out of that yeah my
cemeteries kept getting full wow I
emptied them hardest thing I've ever
heard and I don't want any details yeah
the last one on my list we haven't
mentioned yet is Orion the blindfold
yeah that was a near without my
shortlist that's like way earlier in the
year but this was actually like the
first Metroidvania that I'd ever played
that I was compelled to 100% just
because the thrill of moving the
mechanics of just doing that
backtracking this necessary because of
that kind of game design was
fun it felt like like triple jumping in
Long jumping in mario 64 like I just did
it because I liked it and then it got me
to where I could accomplish other Sheila
it was a beautiful mix of that like
speed and precision bass platforming
especially in those escape levels with
that exploration of a Metroidvania that
I just absolutely plus like this a
better kick start at hearts and movers
10 minutes of that game too orgia valid
or right out of the chest some bill
feels all right gentlemen I we did
pretty good job getting through some
great game all right yeah okay wonderful
job with your egg getting this again
tomorrow so I can come prepared guys
what if all Craig on Twitter he'll have
a list will be tweeting out tomorrow
I'll be updating as a Laurel 24 hours my
list goes that will come back here
alright guys thank you so much enjoy the
rest of your packs like much appreciate
it for coming on stage folks exciting
year so far awesome games and more games
to come here on the live stage here at
PAX Prime we write back